tout homme bien portant est un malade
qui s'ignore écrivait jules renard une
évidence que le langage médical tel
qu'on le pratique est tel qu'on le
découvre dans roulette n'est pas près de
modifier vous allez voir dans l'opinion
sur rue devient pas bio que les gens
bien portants rencontre et on va les
trottoirs sont du câble aux malades
d'incompréhension devant le vocabulaire
de nos cher docteur et pharmaciens de
circulation monsieur oui à quelques
trucs de circulation au moment surtout
du des cars de ramassage des élèves qui
partent comment ça se passe eh bien il
ya un arrêt de la circulation en fin des
troubles c'est surtout place de la
république en face du prisunic pas si
vous avez remarqué alors la tachycardie
à votre avis qu'est ce que ça serait un
rapport capita harbi une province de la
picardie normandie picardie puisque vous
pouvez garder tant que kirby law torino
ça vous dit quelque chose qui ne me
parle pas de mécanique mécanique l'oto
rhino ça vous dit quelque chose
maintenant est ce qu'on n'a pas cette
voiture là non non non pas du tout
que pensez-vous des affections bénignes
madame personnel mais didier pas
beaucoup s'est pas montrée comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure c'est à dire je
n'aime pas beaucoup ces rencontres de
coin de rue c'est je vous disais je suis
pour le 30 à bord quelque chose de
solide
le scorbut scorbut excepté pour les
compétitions de haut niveau où on
s'intéresse à un score pour des matches
de football de rugby très important mise
à part ces grands matches ces grandes
rencontres je n'accorde pas d'importance
au but et au score c'est plutôt l'esprit
du jeu
et la qualité du sport qui m'intéresse
la voie buccale oui oui oui j'aime la
voie buccale
c'est à dire les chansons oui mais
classique la voie buccale mêleront
chanson classique chanson classique wii
la table était chanteur cédric elle
avait une voie buccale aux elle est
chantée au très haut
alors qu'est ce qu'un adjuvant monsieur
mais il ya les allures d adjuvants de
carrière les deux ans d'activité est ce
que c'est qu'un adjuvant et c'est un des
hauts lieux du souletin est au dessus de
sa région enfin quand je vous parle de
pathologies voyez ce que je veux dire
il s'agit de quoi alors non pas qu'ils
aient fait un pas que je sois à la pâte
pourquoi je vois bcg ça vous dit quelque
chose
oui qu'est ce que ça peut être bon chic
bon genre
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quelqu'un qui présente bien par exemple
travaillent chez vous je sais pas je me
posais que kiki qui se serait aussi bien
patrick poivre d'arvor qu il ait bcg
alors bon chic bon genre voilà est-il
pénible à votre avis de garder des
séquelles
j'ai vu un peu ce que c'était il a gardé
des séquelles lui même je pense
effectivement
qu'est ce qui vous paraît pénible dans
le fait de garder des séquelles
garder les moutons en chef dehors et
puis c'est qu'elle sait qu'elle est sous
garde aurier de garde aurier pas de
séquelles tiendrait pas pourquoi